what do i know about a guy that wants to
do drugs and
i know nothing about it sure i've never
done a drug in my life so that's not
your world you're not one dad no getting
married early probably helped you out
from not getting in too much trouble
yeah i mean i i guess yeah one of the
things that helped me is i had no vices
none i liked to gamble but i liked the
casino gamble and i never gambled over
my head plus i had the money i never
sports gambled never did drugs didn't
you know do the women things it just
wasn't in my you know universe which
kept me clean makes sense okay so what
happens next so this now i go out on my
own okay so now it's 1989 okay and i
open up one of the first franchise
operations of a brokerage firm
so with that being said it's like
opening up a subway i didn't own the
broker dealer but i owned the franchise
you're 22 or 23 22. 22 years old you
open up your own place
and that is called financial equity
resources i hooked up with an investment
banker in philadelphia by the name of
howard appel who was absolutely
brilliant and this was my foray into
investment banking this is how i learned
to do investment banking like today they
call them spax
special purpose acquisitions right
corporations back then it was blind
pools so we can raise money off a strong
management team and then go look for the
acquisition and then ultimately that
became the reverse merger play and we
were the kings of it but the blind pool
didn't have as bad of a reputation as
specs do today no no it's too early to
have any bad news
nobody knew anything about it the first
one we did is you may know the guy a
fellow by the name of wayne allen root
no okay he was like an early sports
prognosticator or brilliant guys you
know he's got his blogs and his youtube
thing going he's pretty famous now but
at the time it was it was sports
prognostication
and that was the first blind pool we did
got it so so 22 years old you start your
own place you start doing uh blind pools
you get the management team first you
get the money and then you go find a
business on what you guys want to do
what happens we're doing a lot of
reverse mergers but we're doing quality
deals okay and i think that's what kept
me under what were the deals how big
were the deals you're doing no that was
small deals you know the way you would
normally work if you want me to give you
a little lesson or for your viewers just
understand what a reverse merger is the
publicly traded company is there first
and what that publicly traded company is
is a company that's been stripped down
it might have filed chapter 11 it might
just be a depressed stock that's now
trading at pennies a share so what we
would do is we would let's say seek a
company looking for financing so you
come to me and you say sal i need 10
million dollars in cash we would tell
you well we're not just going to give
you 10 million dollars without having an
already inherent exit strategy can we
explain to you how to go public or that
we could take it
once you're buying in on that we'll use
our own cash maybe give you a million
bucks in cash just to hold you over and
then we'll use that money or other money
additional capital to buy that publicly
traded company because it's trading at
.001 cents a share and there's 50
million shares out there which cost us
nothing so once we've bought and seized
control of that publicly traded company
we're now taking that first emerging the
operating entity into it taking the
company public hence the words reverse
merger the public entity is there first
now we have as much as 20 30 40 of that
stock
that the ceo and his management team as
whatever 20 30 40
you have 10 15 20 of the already
existing shareholders and you create
that merger now the investment banking
work comes in if the stock's trading at
a penny you may want to do a reverse
split make a trade of the dollar if it's
trading at a dollar make it trade a 10
sure but now we have paper
all of that is legal the illegality part
is as the public is buying we're selling
and in order to do that we have to let's
say promote
that stock which is still okay but it's
the additional compensation given to a
licensed stock broker in the form of a
cash payment under the table where he no
longer has his investor's best interest
at heart but lining his own pockets
and that's the illegal part who else was
doing that at the time everybody okay so
even the bigger guys we're doing well i
don't know about the bigger guys but
there's always been additional
compensation i'll give you an example
and this is the way lehman
qualified it they used to be soft dollar
deals so the way lehman used to work is
when they used to get a syndication and
the syndication is for let's say a
company going public they're doing a hot
ipo and everybody knows it's going to be
a hot ipo so ultimately what they would
do is they would get a syndication or a
set amount based on their production so
if patrick was one of the best brokers
he's going to get a hundred thousand
shares of this ipo
now there are uh traders out there that
covet that want that need your ipo
now they can't compensate you so what
they do is they give you an american
express card and they say enjoy yourself
take your wife on vacation go to the bus
go to the strip joints whatever it is we
got
and there is the soft dollar deal that's
what it's called got it so that form or
let's say the practice has been around
forever
it's got different names and and maybe a
different methodology but the practice
itself has been around forever they're
not doing it today anymore though right
how do i know yeah i mean i never talk
about things i don't know yeah finra's
uh
did they have the gift limitation back
in the days to clients or not that they
had a hundred dollar deal right now they
did it
i would have forgot that existed if you
didn't mention it yeah yeah by the way
we were talking about yesterday with a
guy who was a doctor talking about
opioids how these doctors are making all
this money because these big pharma
companies are giving uh
uh you know whining and dying on these
doctors i said if finra gave us a
hundred dollar limit for client maybe
the pharmaceutical industry needs to
have a gift limit that they're giving
their doctors but anyways that's a
complete different conversation it's
difficult to go after big pharma it is
tough nowadays that's why you know
they're doing what they're doing
anyways going back to this so you're
you're 20 to 23
you're you're running your shop you're
doing these blinds it's a very small
shop i got four or five guys okay i got
two so walk me through what happens next
you're doing these deals now this is
where the plot thickens for me so now
i'm making some money decent money more
than anything more than fd yeah on
certain occasions i am yeah but it's
mostly with the undisclosed additional
commissions 100 a month
yeah some months even more okay it
depends so you're making a mill a year
yeah absolutely so now at this point
somebody approaches me and wants me to
finance their finance company it's it's
like an advanced fee loan business
so i look at it i do my due diligence
it's 100 legitimate i agree to bankroll
them
when i do
i throw my dad in there to watch my
investment he's retired at this point so
he's working there and i throw my sister
in there to answer the phones so i have
enough coverage in there or at least i
take solace that they know what they're
doing
so ultimately this becomes a criminal
operation in other words overzealous
sales reps using their fake names
charging advance fees upfront so i'm not
a participant in it i don't contribute
to it but at the end of the day i'm as
guilty as they are the money's going to
be sure
so i'm i'm a participant in this
so with that i think we received
something like 900 inquiries at the
better business bureau in 1990
okay so that encourages and precipitates
a postal service investigation into the
firm i give an interview to the local
paper they knew it was coming i
explained to them nothing is
more valuable to me than the integrity
of my firm my integrity
what they're accusing of is wrong so on
and so forth
ultimately i get indicted my dad gets
indicted my sister gets indicted very
clever on that part because my sister
although she's just answering the phone
is now a party to a conspiracy which
means if i go to trial i'll beat this in
three seconds
but am i going to risk her
and now now i have a problem so i
ultimately have to plead guilty that
guilty plea is going to give me a
mandatory jail sentence one and number
two it's going to ban me from ever
working on wall street again so i agree
i plead guilty
sometime in 92
and in 1993 i started three year
sentence in morgantown west virginia
this is the 30 months that you got
correct okay got it so now when i get
there
i'm in morgantown west virginia
my father's there with me
and if i can be 100 honest i'm having
the time of my life
this was
this was like almost an organized crime
training camp for me
because all the gangsters are there
everybody's talking about their war
stories they're talking about and there
were some big guys that it was the
jackalone family from detroit
and my buddy jackie is now the boss of
the detroit partnership
dead there guys from pittsburgh
youngstown ohio steubenville ohio a
couple of guys from new york so you know
if you look at every crew let's see the
colombians and three or four guys puerto
ricans and three or four guys having
brotherhood of three or four guys we
were like 40 strong
having the time of our life
so this is supposed to discourage me
when i arrive back home i mean if if the
fear is prison
you could take that element out of my
life
and i'm the kid i'm the baby they all
love me i'm carrying things for them i'm
helping them you know everybody called
me the kid the kid that was pretty
popular i was well liked and we had a
ball
so now i get released and i say to
myself okay what's my next move so
before my release i'm doing about six
months worth of research
trying to figure out what my next gig is
and it looks like the head the hottest
sector right now due to the breakup of
the baby bells is long-distance phone
service it looked like like you can make
big money in commissions selling
distance phone service are you talking
like excel communication
cards because the baby bells broke up
yeah so the phone cards is a big
business and you're switching to long
distance service you use att well i'm
working for this company representing
them we could save you 20 30 percent and
i'm going to make a commission of up to
30 percent on your remember the company
names cherry communications got it i
remember quest was doing it too right
that's what's going on
first yeah there was a few lcp
which be no i'm sorry uh
i forgot where it was but that became a
publicly traded new york stock exchange
stock it was a hot sector
so this is what i chose to participate
in
so when i get home i'm looking for bank
i'm looking for you know somebody to
stake me
and a buddy of mine who is the nephew of
a gangster by the name of john gamarano
he approaches me saying look my uncle
will put this up because there's a
pretty popular guy
a strong businessman strong wise guy
well he's not a wise guy but he's not a
maid guy but he's a gangster his name is
joe watts and joe white is making a
fortune in this my uncle wants to put
you two together so i meet with john
gamarano joe watts i go over this whole
business model of what i'm looking to do
joe watts is making a fortune with the
phone cards
so
johnny gamarano agrees to stake me
he does we open up the office i start
doing well
johnny had always assumed that one way
or another i would go back to wall
street in one capacity or another so now
the most interesting part of this in the
trajectory of my life
is now when i return home
less than three years later
everybody's a stockbroker all of bay
ridge
all the bensonhurst
everybody's a broker and everybody is
making a fortune off this new invention
called the world wide web this is 92
99.95 okay 94.95 so now
it's the start or the advent of the
internet
guys are making a killing so this is
when all of these firms
popped out of the woodwork and everybody
was making a fortune now i'm still
relegated to doing the long distance
service i got a nice business i'm
starting to ramp up but the itch to get
back to wall street was always there
so then my original partner howard appel
the guy from philadelphia tells me about
this one stock that he's working it's
called
nal financial and it's backed by even
wayne heisenga here in florida who at
the time was the chairman and the
founder of blockbuster video very
wealthy guy so i think one of the
reasons why i was able to stay under the
radar for so long patrick is because we
always did quality deals like investors
always had a shot there were nobody
there was no customer complaints and if
nobody's complaining we're not on the
radar so with that said we did this nal
financial deal and this was a hot deal
so my job was to find stock brokers to
promote it and then additionally i can
compensate them under the table in cash
and we got off again so now it's may of
1995. i have a wedding to pay for that's
when my wife and i were married i needed
money i needed to jump back into this
universe and now i'm noticing all this
mob influence on wall street you had so
many wise guys involved who had a piece
of this what a piece it is what a piece
of this any big names or no uh yeah you
had uh
like
it's probably better for me if i don't
get that specific if you don't mind what
were they bosses involved the
underbosses like the high rates they're
always involved sure yeah you had a lot
of you had a lot of skippers a lot of
couples that were involved in this the
money was too good not to and let me
just say something the mob has always
been on wall street it may be different
capacity i don't care if you know they
they find a box of zero coupon bonds but
the point is the mob has always had an
influence on wall street so if you like
this sort of short clip from an
interview i did click over here to watch
the entire interview and
please don't forget to subscribe to the
channel take care everybody bye-bye
so